[Music]
how deLee doodlee reject nation
patronage ex whoever happens to be
watching this it's your boy hump asaurus
rex in the building to check out a new
song from mr. Jack white that's right
experimenting checking out some tunes
here on the channel just did a video
about that new Mike Shinoda EP so I
thought maybe I'll check this out too
and as always if you want to see the
uncut stuff come on over to patreon
we're testing all kinds of new things
out over there got TV show reactions
music video reactions we got exclusive
videos and requests and stuff it's a lot
of fun come check that out but the
highlights will be here on YouTube and
this is from Jack's upcoming album
boarding house reach his third solo
project and her there are a lot of
different influences at work on this
album including rhyming you know it's
Jack White's there's obviously gonna be
some rock and roll some bluegrass stuff
but also I've heard hard funk electro
proto pop hip hop and that vibe kind of
came across to me in what's called
connected by love that vibes sort of
started to hit me with the rumble II
synth bass sounds and some of the
heavier beats and things still very much
a jack white Tambor tune you know a few
people in the music sphere of sort of
theorized that this is gonna be his
electronic album and I could definitely
see that happening I got that vibe off
of connected by love for sure with the
way the beats sort of sounded like that
a hip-hop influence anyway he's using
some more synth bass lines and stuff
like that a little bit more rumbly in
the sounds but you know it's Jack white
so I don't imagine he would ever release
something there's just like a hundred
percent electronic but anyhow this is
the third song from his new album I like
connected by love okay the beast side of
that single I liked a lot more respect
commander was a lot more grabby in my
opinion and kind of gave me a better
picture I thought of what the album
might look like it's a weird sort of
unruly song off the cuff and I really
like that thick beat some wailing
guitars and stuff so I'm excited for
this and this new song here is called
corporation so let's check this out
let's do it
[Music]
I'd off the map
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
really funky
[Applause]
[Music]
does love Led Zepplin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
who's with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's that super fuzz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mayo woozi's now
[Applause]
is that women
loves that whammy pedal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh it comes that beat again alright okay
well hearing this song especially on the
heels of the reading I just did I can
definitely get a better sense for what
he's going for with this record I mean
that it definitely borrows from some of
that hard funk he was talking about
there's I mean that beat is thick you
know reminded me of a hip hop beat this
song yeah if you watch the full reaction
you'll see me laughing a whole lot and
one thing I've noticed about myself just
as a consumer of various media is that
when things are especially I don't know
clever to me or take me by surprise I
tend to giggle I tend to laugh at them
and I kind of cackle through this whole
song because this is super duper off the
cuff man Jack white is deep into his
Korea's third solo album he's released
so much music over time and there's
definitely stuff on all Jack solo albums
I think is terrific I do return to them
but my favorite stuff about Jack white
isn't necessarily a lot of his solo
material however this song right here an
especially respect commander are really
gripping me with the sense of fun
restraints that are they wild and
they're kind of off the walls and and
sort of screeching and dissonant and
groovy all at the same time this song
especially it's got a weird structure
it's got a lot of groove to it I like
that he's still mixing it up and getting
wild I guess that's the thing is like
listening to Jack's solo albums there is
a certain amount of prowess there's a
lot more musicians involved and there is
a certain amount of polish so hearing
this something that really does sound
kind of off the dome and and wild again
I really have enjoying quite a lot so
far so I'm I'm getting excited for this
record more and more that I hear from it
I love hearing Jack White try on the
funk side of things with this I mean
there's a really groovy sort of funky
bass line and then there's this like Led
Zeppelin guitar harmony thing or there
it's it's it's reminds me of some
specific song I can't draw to mind right
now I'm really excited to hear him play
with some new sounds on this album some
new genres and things and you know as
much as I do love especially now the
presence of things that are analog
organic in some way especially with rock
music's rock music has had a difficult
time adapting to the modern age in some
respects a lot of people are kind of
trading in their guitars for
synthesizers everybody's kind of become
and imagine dragons a little bit and I
like that jack is participating in this
wave of rock musicians are rock centric
musicians jumping into more modern
aesthetics but I feel like Jack is such
a journeyman that he's gonna draw from
elements of these genre across the board
across the history I gotta imagine he's
gonna bring an interesting angle to it
and I'm really excited to hear him work
with some more electro some more hip-hop
sounds see how he brings them into his
mix because you know what the jackets
never gonna devolve into just a Pro
Tools extravaganza there's something
about his music that's always I think
gonna feel organic and feel real and so
I'm actually excited to hear that he's
working in some of these territories and
I bet he's gonna bring in some sounds
that maybe aren't so popular right now -
so boardinghouse reach man I am very
curious about this album and I cannot
wait to hear it hopefully get to see him
live but yeah what did you guys think
share your thoughts in the comments
below are you looking forward to the new
that are you looking forward to this new
Jack White joint hit us up and as always
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
updated every time a review or a video
is out and come visit us on patreon like
I said the uncut version of this will be
over there and don't forget to check us
out on the Stardust app people we're
having lots of fun over there a lot of
big youtubers are on it Sam check out
the link in the comment box and I will
see you on the next one should should
should shoes